there are 2.2 million apps on the app
store
but really you only need to know about
five of them
what's going on guys my name is david
thomage and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here thank you so much for
joining me as i've already mentioned
my name is david thomas i'm a masters of
architecture graduate
and on this channel we talk about
technology and architecture
predominantly for architects and
architecture students
today we're talking about the five apps
that you need on your ipad or any tablet
that you're using
to be able to do your job effectively
now in by no way shape or form
any of these apps one sponsored or
too generic every single app is
highly purposeful and targeted at your
job you may not
realize it especially if you're not in
the profession yet but you will use
all of these apps almost every single
day so app one
more folio trace if you don't know what
morpholio trace is
it is a very targeted app at the
architecture profession
it allows you to draw document and just
trace freely like you were with normal
butter paper
so you have the ability to start
sketching out your floor plans your
sections your elevations whatever it
might be
overlay a piece of butter paper make
some adjustments
overlay another piece of butter paper
make some more adjustments
maybe you don't like that one turn that
layer off put another layer on
and just keep going really get your flow
and understanding of the concept design
out very well
now morfolio trace has a lot more
capabilities than that
but personally speaking that is the
extent of what i use it for
it gives you the ability to even take in
some pdfs of
the job that's been documented overlay a
piece of butter paper
you can change it from yellow light
yellow to white or transparent whatever
color you want
and then start marking up your changes
so if you're sitting in a client meeting
for example
and you need to document the changes
that the client is talking about
you're going through the drawings page
by page you can quickly start
tracing over that document without
ruining the pdf
it is basically the high-tech version of
tracing paper
that's the best way i can put it but it
is a very
versatile app that you at least need to
try out
it does have a free version there is a
paid version as well
if you start using it more and more
you'll probably end up getting the paid
version
just because i think it's like 12 bucks
a year or something it's not very
expensive
and it gives you a lot more freedom to
import more data
as you need it number two onedrive
onedrive is not an architect or
architecture student specific app but
seriously if you do not have a cloud
system jump onto onedrive
i recommend this one because i use
office 365 so much word excel all those
things
and it integrates really really well by
having onedrive you have the ability
to bring up any drawing any photo any
document
anywhere in the world and share it with
anybody
so the limitations of sending over 10
megabytes via email are gone
the limitations of calling up the office
and going i've forgotten this drawing
can you email it to me or can you bring
somebody
with the printed documentation are gone
you now have the ability
to quickly and easily access
any single file ever produced in your
office
now i don't know about you guys but that
makes my job
so much easier we transitioned from a
server-based system a couple years ago
to the cloud
and man i don't know why we didn't do it
sooner but the cloud system is
phenomenal at number three microsoft
teams
coverts really changed how we do
practice
and how the world operates in general no
longer are we isolated and
stuck inside our cubicles for hours on
end never speaking to anybody
and we're no longer having face-to-face
meetings
as regularly it is now a lot more common
to have a video conference with a whole
bunch of people
at any time of the day or night people
have become a lot more accepting of it
and now also just learnt to use the
programs
microsoft teams again is something that
i recommend because
it falls into that microsoft suite so it
just integrates with my workflow
very well you can use anything from zoom
to skype to webex whatever i actually do
have a video comparing them if you want
to check it out
but it is a very important app to have
on your ipad in 2020
number four microsoft to do again
another microsoft app
because i use the microsoft platform it
can be
any to-do list you can think of but
having a to-do list
is essential you're going to get
bombarded with so many requests so many
emails so many tasks to do
clients are going to give you
information you just
you're just going to forget
realistically you need to be able to
organize
and manage your information very well
so having 100 emails come in a day
reading through them all and going okay
i need to do this this this and this
i'm not going to do that now i'm going
to put on my to-do list and get to it
but continue doing my job makes it so
much easier that when you do transition
to that job you just look at the to-do
list
go through it one by one by one and just
get it done
you don't have to sit there going
through hundreds of emails
thinking back to all the meetings you've
had and just trying to remember all this
information
you have it all compacted and concise
now personally i am a little bit biased
here because i use a to-do list in my
everyday life
i use it for everything it reminds me to
buy things at the shops
to do things when i get home to reply to
people that i haven't spoken to in
months
and to run all my businesses at the same
time as working a full-time job
there is many things that you remember
but there is many things you forget so
having it all written down
and that information available anywhere
because it's on the app
it's on the cloud it can be accessed
anywhere around the world
it is very very important that you learn
to start using these to-do lists and
finally the fifth app i recommend
is notes now i use apple notes for a
number of reasons
predominantly for the fact of its
versatility and freedom to do whatever
you want it also gives you
the freedom to file and document and
order
all of your jobs based on that job
number so if you have a hundred meetings
with one client you can store that
all under the one client folder and then
you can have
all different notes for a different
client or a different project i've tried
to use a whole bunch of different notes
apps and trying
to slowly convert everybody in the
office to a digital form of note-taking
and so far notes is the best form
for the architecture profession simply
for the fact that
it allows you to be creatively free if
you have to
just scribble down some notes and take
minutes you can do that
if you have to type some notes you can
do that if you have to sketch out
a floor plan mark up some details or
showcase an image to the client you can
do that
if you need it put up your ipad take a
photo of something on site
draw all over it file it in that note
section
you can again do that and it's all
stored to the cloud
so it's automatically filed i go on
about filing and documenting so much
because it is a very big part of your
job as well as
obviously designing and documenting
buildings this is
one element of your job and it's the
best part of your job
but in reality there is so much
communication so much teamwork so much
collaboration
and so much information that needs to be
retained and accessible at any given
time
to ensure that project is mastered
and when it's built it's absolutely
perfect now i'll quickly show you guys
what i have on my ipad as well
it's very minimalistic i don't have a
lot of apps because
i generally just use my ipad for work
purposes
productivity is probably the best folder
that i have for everything that i use
word excel adobe skype things like that
photoshop lightroom they get used on a
very regular day-to-day basis a power
mirror if you're wondering is actually
used for these youtube videos so i can
mirror
the device that i'm recording on onto
the ipad so i can kind of understand
what's going on
make sure things are in focus usually at
the bottom of the dock i'll have
google chrome i'll have outlook i'll
have notes
and i'll have my to-do list i'll
occasionally put
a third-party app down there if i need
to use split screen
but those four are generally what is
down there in my dock and used
every single day non-stop anyway that's
all for me today guys thank you so much
for watching the video i hope you
enjoyed it
if you did make sure you smash that like
button to help the video with the
youtube algorithm
believe it or not it really really helps
the channel grow
and get exposed to more people so the
more people that watch
the more people will hopefully hit that
like button if you want to see more of
my content
hit that subscribe button and you'll get
a new video from me every single monday
this week i've tried to produce three
pieces of content
hopefully this is the third and final
piece you've seen if not
well i didn't achieve my goal anyway
thank you so much for joining me
and i'll see you next time